in singapore a highly anticipated
gathering came to a close
speaking after meeting with the u.s
secretary of defense the chinese
minister of defense general wei fung heu
told reporters it went smoothly he said
the talks were honest and sincere
defense secretary lloyd austin said they
covered global and regional issues al
jazeera understands it included
discussion of the war in ukraine as well
as some of the regional flashpoints
including taiwan and the south china sea
what we've seen
on the south china sea is that despite
the pandemic
problematic actions in the south china
sea have continued these include number
one
chinese encroachments upon the exclusive
economic zones of various coastal states
the defence chiefs met on the sidelines
of the shangri-la dialogue the most
significant security summit in the
region
organizers say the importance of the
three-day conference is mostly about
what happens behind closed doors
if you're one of the more than two dozen
defense ministers that come to the
shangri-la dialogue you're coming not
just to speak but in order to have a
range of bilateral meetings
secretary austin also met with defence
officials from southeast asia as the u.s
seeks to reassure countries of its
commitment to the region while beijing's
influence continues to rise china's
engagement on the economic front has
been sustained not just um
in the last year or two but it's been
sustained over decades
in terms of its trade engagement with
the region while most of the world's
attention will be on the us and china
for other countries in the region the
summit is also a chance to re-establish
their defence priorities and connect
with their peers
japanese prime minister fumio kishida
told delegates his country wants to
contribute to peace in the asia pacific
we must not repeat the scourge of
nuclear weapons the threat of nuclear
weapons let alone the use should never
be tolerated as the prime minister of
the only country that has suffered the
devastation of atomic bombings i
strongly appeal for this
the shangri-la dialogue is taking place
after a two-year hiatus and with growing
concerns about the region's stability
experts say it's a timely return jessica
washington al jazeera singapore